I won't play this little game of figures
because I hope shops from Britain but I
will be next week in China and South
Korea I will be in December in Japan I
will go to New York again this is not
only about brexit this is about
transforming France in showing that
France has entered a new era politically
speaking economically speaking and
socially speaking so we are building
something new and this is happening in
France
I won't tell figures until it is sign
you know it is very South America I
believe only what I see and you must
have a number in mind I mean it's quite
often said this has been long period in
mind it's office in London it's the
fifth biggest city in yahrens three
hundred thousand French people how many
how many Brits would you like to see
living in Paris a lot because of course
we we have a strong relationship with
the UK for a long time Martha and my
first internship here 20 years ago in
London and of course we will be very
happy to welcome some Brits in in Paris
to work what is important to say that
when you attract someone in a city
working the financial sector you create
2 to 4 indirect jobs because an
investment banker coming to a city it is
also good news for the content services
for the legal services and so on and so
this creates an ecosystem which is good
for the economy so hopefully the worst
we can but I mean Frankfurt can offer
close proximity to the European Central
Bank for example Luxembourg has a
separate regulator for insurers and it's
attracting a lot of insurance companies
what's what's Paris's unique selling
point
we have many first we have an
educational system which is very
performative on finance issues because
most of our engineers and business
called our classic are maybe in the top
10 in Europe second we have a regulatory
system that is recognized by everyone as
one of the best in the world and which
is very rare
for a lot of bank bankers and also
insurance company yesterday chub which
is a an American insurer announced he
was organizing is it quarter in Paris is
European aid quarter so this is what we
are presenting right now but we are not
simply doing that because of the present
issues we are building something in a
long term perspective and we want to
basically show that we are able to build
a sustainable pro-business environment
in the long term meaning five to ten
years not only regarding March 2019 with
the brexit issues apart from HSBC there
haven't been that many banks that have
so far committed to creating lots of
jobs in Paris does that disappoint you
well first HSBC announced that it will
reallocate 1,000 employees in Paris and
we have very good discussions when with
a lot of banks but you know people like
discretion
we haven't been giving information about
our discussion with his American insurer
until it announced itself that he was
going to set up in Paris so we are in a
very good negotiation with many banks
many American banks and also some
electrons so you're quite confident that
there will be others following probably
and again we are we have one mission
demonstrate that what we have said
during the political campaign during the
presidential campaign and the
parliamentary election is implemented
quickly and probably nobody would have
believed when we were running the
election that the labor market
flexibility reform would be implemented
in less than a hundred days in France
because I was reading this morning in
the Economist very known newspaper that
who read in front that the labor market
was also all was almost organized by
calm acts
philosophy in France well apparently
Karl Marx is not here anymore
and we are welcoming people from
everywhere in the world